um
for people who have obviously kind of
break down like the section of la you're
from
like you know i think anybody who who's
fans of nip and
are already tapped in with your movement
kind of already understand where you're
from but like for people who are
watching this
who don't know kind of like give us a
background on what part of la you're
from
i'm from l.a i'm from south central you
know what i'm saying the crenshaw
district
you know i'm saying i grew up on 8th ave
you know i'm saying i went to hyde park
elementary went to crenshaw high
washington high
you know what i'm saying it's crazy
because because crenshaw high has become
like a cultural
like landmark you know and i know nip
had a lot to do with that
like even back to when he had uh those
pony shoes and they were
the blue and the yellow and yeah hell
yeah yeah
yeah man crenshaw crenshaw itself man
you know what i'm saying got a history
within
itself you from saying and and and
and nip and nip you know what i'm saying
he just recreated
the history of it you know what i'm
saying we had history then with the
daryl
strawberry and of course you know what
i'm saying and all that
and yeah man it brought that [ __ ] back
to life bro on a worldwide
international scale like you know what
i'm saying